so my relationship with Halloween All
Saints Day and the idea of saints in
general is very strange you see I was
raised in a very conservative
conservative and fundamentalist
nomination of Christianity for roughly
18 years of my life pretty much from
birth till I came to Yale I was one of
Jehovah's Witnesses a couple of years
before I was born my parents who were at
the time run of the middle 20-something
Mexican Catholic immigrants took heat of
the gospel being preached at their door
and they converted a couple years later
I was born to boy it'll boil it all down
all I ever knew was life inside this
religion and life as a Jehovah's Witness
kid is tough no birthdays no Boy Scouts
no Christmas no Easter and of course the
Halloween now if you want me to explain
all the theological and doctrinal
intricacies of why the jobs witnesses
choose not to celebrating in any of
these please find me after worship and
I'll gladly explain I'm a really two
studies major I live for this kind of
stuff anyways growing up I was thought
of the Saints of the strange foreign and
definitely Catholic idea that didn't
quite square with how I understood my
relationship with God in Jesus however
as I faded away from the job as
witnesses as I shifted towards
mainstream Christianity and as my faith
matured I began to formulate a more
solid idea of who the Saints were to me
now I don't have all the stuff about how
the saints might be intercessors between
us and God hammered out yet whether or
not the Saints occupy a different space
and this hierarchy of the faithful it's
not really something i'm concerned with
I do however think I've identified some
Saints in my own life this brings me to
this ridiculously oversized stole that
I'm warning today you see this stole
belongs to one of the Saints in my life
some of you might know him his name is
John gage and he preaches right across
the street at United Church on the green
if you've ever met him you know that
John is a big guy barrel chested and
muscle bound as he is John definitely
exudes strength however aside from
physical strength I admire John for a
spiritual strength John I have a couple
things in common we're both foodies with
an affinity for the fries a116 crown
and the mac and cheese of kassius we
both major in religious studies at Yale
albeit with 19 years between our
graduating years but most importantly at
least to me is the fact that we're both
gay men in the Christian faith seeing
lesbian gay bisexual and transgender
people living their lives fully as
Christians is something i never had
growing up and something i didn't know
was possible until i left home and came
to yell seeing people like John lived
her life reminds me of the love God
feels towards his children it reminds me
of the words of the Prophet Jeremiah
where he says how God newest before we
were formed in our mother's womb before
we were born we were set apart as his to
me seeing people like John reinforces my
belief that despite where I came from or
who I was God already loved me and
accepted me despite whatever I was
taught to me that love of God is a big
oversized thing much like this stole
that wraps us up and holds us even
though we don't know it like our Lord
Jesus Christ illustrates in the Gospel
of Luke God wishes to cover us and hold
us like a hand gathering her chicks
under her wings if the saints are meant
to be spiritual role models for us then
John definitely is one for me as I
mature my Christian faith I recently the
Christian faith that I recently
reclaimed I clearly see the need for a
church that has positive Frank and
affirming discussions around where
lesbian gay bisexual and transgender
people fit into the fog my experiences
as a gay Christian led me to become a
religious studies and at queer studies
major it also led me to search out the
university church as an open and
affirming place to live this newfound
faith it also led me to find a saint
like John if you don't I can only hope
that in the future my life leads me to
be to find more Saints like John and
people in this church and God willing
become a saint for someone myself
when i was younger i looked at my
grandma with a sense of amazement we
would drive down to visit her home a
farm west of st. Louis for us it was a
vacation spot for her it was the place
where she had lived since childhood the
land where her grandfather father
husband and son had raised cattle corn
and soybeans and the place she raised
her own family I thought she was so
strong and tough even though i grumbled
when this manifested in rules like no
food not even milk between meals i
watched in wonder as she extinguished
candle flames between her arthritic
thumb and forefinger were walked
tirelessly up and down the rows tending
her expansive garden she had endured
events that i could only imagine or
learn about in history class the Great
Depression a world war a heart attack
and triple bypass surgery several floods
several droughts she had seen an unborn
child parents and later a sister and her
beloved husband died amidst it all she
cared for her family raising five
children in a home that was heated by a
wood-burning stove and did not have
indoor plumbing until my grandma was 50
years old and my mother the youngest of
the five was in high school I had never
seen grandma cry she rarely complained
yet for all of her toughness she was
also the same grandma who rollers in her
hair beckoned my brother sister and me
to sit on her lap for devotions who kept
packs of big red and Doublemint gum in
the back closet for us and who always
opened her home and had homemade meals
ready as I grew I began to realize how
integral my grandma and her strength was
to our family though this strength
deserved wonder it wasn't just a novelty
I began to see how she had given my
grandpa great strength and support how
she nurtured each of her five children
turn each of her 19 grandchildren it
seems there was hardly a trial or
tribulation she hadn't faced through it
all she remains strong leaning on the
one who gave her strength she relied on
the word trusting God and God's plan and
built our family on this foundation
grandma knew well that earthly life was
temporary and fleeting time to bide
until reaching her heavenly home she was
grounded by her faith sure of her
ultimate goal the things of this world
of earthly life were little significance
our family loves baseball and were
diehard Cardinals fans my mom's favorite
player of all time is Hall of Fame left
fielder Lou Brock and she kept a poster
in her old bedroom of Lou sliding into
Cielo base on one of our visits to the
farm however we went up to her room to
discover that the poster of Lou Brock
had been replaced by a painting of jesus
now my mom was not actually upset about
the switch in and of itself but she
wanted to know where the poster had gone
so she could take it home with us my
grandma had no idea the poster was
thrown in the trash or forever lost my
grandma was surprised that my mom was
upset by this and reminded her it's just
earthly things grandma's gaze was always
heavenward over the recent years my
grandma's health
my grandma's health and cognitive
function declined even through that time
though she never feared death instead
she looked forward with joyful
anticipation to the day she would go to
heaven to meet her Lord to be reunited
with her family who had gone before in
may I had the privilege of being with my
grandma during the last moments of her
earthly life my aunts uncles and cousins
had stayed with her throughout the day
and my mom sister brother and I
surrounded her into the night we read
her confirmation verse Isaiah 54 10
though the mountains be shaken and the
hills be removed yet my unfailing love
for you will not be shaken nor my
covenant of peace be removed my mom lay
with my grandma as they had so many
times before and with her hand over my
grandma's chest my mom felt my grandma's
last heartbeat as she left us to receive
new life I apologized to my grandma for
the tears I cried that night and for the
tears yet to come because I know it was
not a sad moment for her I was and am
still working on building my own
strength I am NOT the woman my grandma
was but I am ever thankful that gossip
God saw fit to bless my life was such a
woman who had so much to teach me the
things of this life come and go life
comes and goes but Christ and the
promise of eternal life is constant I'd
like to close by sharing the words of a
letter my grandma wrote to our family
jun 2nd 1989 to my dear children spouses
and grandchildren who knows when our
final hour will come be ready for that
day all your lifetime my one desire and
hope has been that you will cherish the
one thing needful and believe that
wisdoms highest noblest treasure is your
belief in Jesus and his saving grace it
will be heaven if we are all there thank
you for having been good thoughtful
children
and forgive my mistakes and failures as
a mother keep christ in you and he will
help you over the rough places of life
and give you much joy I pray that the
Lord will keep the circle of our family
unbroken when we stand before him on the
day of judgment my life has been a full
and happy one on this earth with
trusting and the Lord this is my wish
for you also your loving mother
mother-in-law and grandmother Alma